bonjour bruno naisseur à 0 bonjour mon
fils bien le ton maire de sainte marie
député du nord de la martinique bruno
nestor azérot pourquoi personne n'a
jamais cru un moment fait que vous
n'allez pas vous représenter que vous ne
seriez pas candidat à votre propre
succession mu vient de tomber les gars
de l'actualité je veux avant tout
présenter mes voeux de bonne et cette
année à la population martiniquaise
puisque je crois qu'il faut qu'on soit
réhabilité de valeurs et de repères
maintenant ce que j'ai tout simplement
envie de dire mauvais tour quand vous
êtes élu vous ne vous appartenez plus à
vous même vous appartenez à vos
populations et en tant que président de
mouvement vous appartenez à votre
mouvement
donc je suis tout simplement aujourd'hui
à travers ce qui s'est passé ce vote qui
s'est passé au conseil d'administration
du mip candidats aux éléments initiative
populaire de vous m'annoncez atteint
vague populaire de candidats aux états
unis qu'à ça il va presser le mouvement
qui a hésité
le mouvement a beaucoup hésité je crois
qu aujourd'hui lorsqu'on regarde les
résultats qui sont les nôtres sur la
ville de sète marie et plus largement
sur la circonscription mais je crois que
nous avons un bilan à défendre
oui vous allez me cette marie au centre
de tout pour vous donner ce à 0 j'exige
avery a fait de vous ce que vous êtes et
donc vous attendez je lui dois beaucoup
vous apprêtez à passer la main à les
mettre quelqu'un d'autre à la tête de la
mairie en cas de réélection à la
législatives de juin prochain
vous savez un mauvais bulletin c'est pas
une histoire d'hommes c'est une histoire
d'équipé
il me semble que lorsque je suis à
l'assemblée nationale puisque monde est
toujours en cours la mairie est bien
gardé et il ya des hommes et des femmes
qui font très bien leur boulot ce sens
de dire que vous tirez vous allez tirer
les ficelles je n'ai jamais dit ça je
considère que nous sommes avant tout une
équipe d'élus à égalité à sept maris
c'est une organisation politique qui
fonctionne très bien et je crois que eu
égard des résultats qui sont les nôtres
à cette marche puisque vous avez parlé
de cette marque d'abord et plus
largement de la circonscription mais je
crois que ce qui existait à l'époque
offre à licques et ses airs plus très
bien qui a produit du résultat peut très
bien être transporté sur cette manne
offre vous acceptez déjà le principe de
redevenir un simple conseiller municipal
conseiller
pourquoi ces peut conseiller municipal
je serai un élu de la ville nationale
mais pourquoi en parler de vos six pour
la présidence de cap nord un juste
retour des choses puisque vous y avez
fait la pluie et le beau temps par
influence ça ne vous a pas tenté un
moment ça vous savez je crois qu'il y a
suffisamment d'hommes et de femmes
hommes en tunique investi d'une mission
emolo pays et on ne peut pas il faut que
ces personnes là soit un peu dispersés
dans les différentes collectivités je
crois que c'est ce qui se fait à travers
mon ami alfred monthieux effectivement
je peux dire que j'ai pris une part très
active très active pour qu'il soit
président de cette nouvelle collectivité
mais pourtant vous devrez saisir une
communauté d'agglomération c'est ce qui
devrait attiser toutes les convoitises
les communautés deviennent le socle du
pouvoir avec toutes ces nouvelles
compétences l'eau le tourisme ça peut
être plus excitants comme challenge mais
je crois que ce que je réalise sur sept
maris ce que je fais en tant que député
me permet d'être et poigne pleinement et
celui de me voir aujourd'hui donc je
crois comme mon ami alfred monthieux et
épanouie également de la mission qui est
la sienne donc voila quoi on fonctionne
très bien pour nous mais ça se fera dans
quelques jours avec la réunion du
mouvement initiative populaire simple
formalité dans le nord il ya déjà des
candidats d'annoncer marcellin nadeau de
nous déplacer tel ya à peu près 72
heures justin pamphile sous la bannière
pmn et pia yan monplaisir de la droite
qui se tâtent que pensez vous de tout
cela mais je pense tout simplement que
nous sommes dans un pays démocratique
qui est la france et que ce sont des
élections donc c'est tout à fait normal
que dès qu'il y ait des candidats qui se
présentent à ses étudiants cela pour ce
geste là maintenant ce sont nos
populations de décider qui fera quoi et
un drop à personne je n'ai jamais dit ça
seulement l'europe est pressée en
population mais je crois que les
populations vont vous juger à travers la
visibilité de l'action politique
c'est tout simplement ça et je suis très
content puisque moutons franchement
lorsqu'on regarde le monde entier
combien de peuples se bat pour avoir
cette démocratie et le droit de voter de
pouvoir voter
donc aujourd'hui que nous avons ce
pouvoir
il faut qu'on nous l'exerçons mais je
crois que le ce qui est plus intéressant
même si à cette défiance de la
population vis-à-vis de la chose
politique dans ce geste rendez ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ce sont les
populations nos populations qui décide
je crois qu'aujourd'hui la morosité est
tel que parce le moment c'est que ce
soit en france aux états unis partout la
morosité et là le monde va mal on est
tout à fait d'accord donc il faut quand
même des élus qui vous redonne un peu
d'espoir nous ne sommes pas jésus christ
nous ne sommes pas le christ pour tout
faire je ne l'avons pas ce pouvoir là
mais nous devons en tout cas essayer de
faire la politique de petits pas gagner
chaque jour un petit pas pour que nous
puissions améliorer les conditions de
vie de nos concitoyens
on vous dit vous donner c'est à 0 très
proche de serge letchimy flirtant même
parfois avec lui les mauvaises langues
vont même à dire que le camp du
président du ppm a choisi celui qui
pourrait perdre plus facilement face à
vos ce qui ne serait pas très élégant
pour par exemple le maire du lorrain
juste enfin fils qu'est ce que tu
racontes
je vais pas entrer dans les laits dans
les confidences du bpm ou de martinique
nouvelle ça je suis tout simplement
boulonnais radio qui ne fait partie
d'aucune écurie et ça a toujours été le
cas
maintenant je crois que je me suis
retrouvé assis à côté d'un siège de
chimie parce que nous sommes tous les
deux nous supportons tous les deux
manuel valls
manuel valls c'est lui le président du
comité de soutien donc je suis tout le
monde connaît ma proximité avec manuel
valls d'ailleurs si la banane a été
aussi défendu si la can a été aussi
défendu si la circonscription est entré
d'adressé c'est parce que j'ai toujours
eu le soutien de manuel valls entend
d'abord que ministre de l'intérieur
et ensuite premier ministre qu'il faut
quand même être loyal je suis loyal avec
lui donc
et puis aussi j'ai envie de dire que que
ce soit sur la chimie
alfred marie-jeanne marcellin nadeau les
autres nous sommes des élus martiniquais
nous pouvons être 4 bits et
d'orientations différentes nous pouvons
avoir des idées différentes mais nous
sommes avant tout des élus martiniquais
s'est pas vraiment relâchée mais la cie
population martinique là n'essayez pas
c'est pas les immigrés des mre à ces
populations martinique la de poutine ou
peut pas travailler ensemble tous les
jours vous demandez ce que les élus
travaillent ensemble les atermoiements
de yan monplaisir
comment vous regardez ça celui qui avait
de si bons chiffres auparavant et qui
aujourd'hui zitte se demande
à quoi faire vous savez mon vélo je vous
pensais l'exemple aux élections
municipales de cette marie nous avons
plus d orientation au premier rang
desquels l'organisation du transport
aujourd'hui la cité un appeau
compétences l'organisation du transport
il ya de montplaisir a été élu à un an
il ya beaucoup de travail énormément de
travail que ce soit lui ou les autres
donc je crois que je disais qu'il faut
que les élus soient un peu partout là où
ils sont utiles c'est à dire les textes
n'aura qu'a dit la vie naturelle ou
moins ce serait bien justement que cette
collectivité met en place le transport
urbain et notamment si le nom et
singulièrement sur cette marque vous
travaillez sans gros chantier donc il
suffit pas que chaque veulent veut y
aller
toujours dans des postes mais il faut
que l'ingestion d'eau n'est pas ce que
nous faire savoir de votre part exploser
l'avion
ça c'est votre analyse en tout cas je
pense que nos populations
ça fait un an que la septième est mise
en place il ya rien à faire au sein de
cette collectivité est réservé aux
affaires boulonnais sont à zéro le g20 a
refait son apparition alors que l'on
croyait tous la mort enterré après
décembre 2015 avec des répercussions sur
vous le des acteurs de sélection l'un
des acteurs de cette série de réunions
faussement et hypocritement secrète un
g20 qui touche et qui nuit à votre ami à
votre frère l'autre député celui du sud
jour fini lors vous n'avez jamais tu
votre amitié pour le meilleur et pour le
pire avec et le pire avec jean-philippe
ni lors comment vivez-vous tout cela
tous les deux le fait que ça revienne
comme ça sur le devant de la scène
je réitère ce que j'ai dit nous sommes
de ce pays de démocratie donc chacun est
libre de discuter d'échanger comme il
l'entend je rappelle moto que je ne fais
partie d'aucune écurie effectivement
j'étais très content de participer à ce
groupe de réflexion d'échangés de
discuter savait et et d'ailleurs c'est
important que nous l'ayons fait en ces
termes et à ce moment là d'ici 2020 je
pense que nous aurons à proposer autre
chose
donc là je ne sais pas fini même soin de
toi vous mélangez
voeux n'a jamais est toujours vivant
plus que jamais avec ces jeux volonté de
travailler renouvellement de
l'atlantique mais mais de toutes les
manières cela s'impose à nous alfred
marie jeanne a déjà annoncé qu'il ne
sera plus candidat à la députation
donc ça veut dire que l'on reconnaît que
c'est son dernier mandat c'est lui même
qui l'a dit ce n'est pas moi mais
attendez il faut qu'ils aient des
renouvellements vous devez fournir et
puis attendre ça tout simplement
renouvellement de la classe politique
tout comme vous également mot viol temps
les eaux plus calmes et fauqué ni en
droit nouvellement quand on est
journaliste
ainsi va la vie mot viol tôt on ne peut
rien faire contre c'est tout à fait
naturel
beney restera léo n'est pas éternel d'où
ne la soigne on ne sera pas toujours
être aux habitants que débuter ni en
tant que maire s il faut qu'ils n'ont
pas failli le rôle est également resté
un moment donné est ce que à 0,4 y y et
ni l'eau pour gagnant pas la dot d'agde
états généraux à qui je souhaite un
prompt rétablissement et nous sommes
toujours très amis nous sommes toujours
très lié et de la r nous travaillons
tous les deux pour le développement de
la martinique en tant que député de la
nation française
et puis journalières général et tous les
bruits tous les médecins you say you but
n'est pas homme à sa démo karman est de
voir fait choisi des options money doit
récemment les fautifs au moment dé
quitus à un monde marie jeanne a vu son
parc au marie jeanne a été peut-être
comme moi aussi virulent à l'époque
et pourquoi je ne peux pas l'être
aujourd'hui 4 qui m'ont empêcherait le
droit la virulence ce que je n'ai jamais
dit que c'est le voile à vue le 20 mai
le droit à l'existence d'une certaine
manière à se propulser est à dire les
choses d'une certaine manière vous
trouvez que le débat politique propre
aujourd'hui avec des bruits là la
différence en pire
c'est la politique maintenant il ya les
politiques et la politique - politique
l'amour à poney et pitau pro maintenant
il ya les politiques
donc je fais la différence maintenant
chacun défend sa thèse de la manière
dont il entend mais je pense que
personnellement le débat politique d'une
manière générale est nécessaire et il
est très instructif pour la population
martiniquaise
maintenant je réitère ce que j'ai dit
c'est cette population là qu'il décidera
toujours a conscience merci vous donner
ce réservoir était avec ton répète nous
candidat à votre propre succession à la
députation dans le nord est cassé le
mythe qui décidera officiellement de
votre investiture le 22 janvier prochain
bonne journée je vous remets à ces
mondiaux le ton